now turning to a bombshell revelation
donald trump insisted people inside his
administration were working to undermine
his presidency and it turns out he was
right as a new book from bob woodward
and robert acosta reveals the chairman
of the joint chief of staff mark milley
sought to undermine trump
while he served as commander-in-chief
millie had at least two phone calls with
his counterpart in chinese and the
chinese government where he looked to
reassure the communist nation that the
u.s wouldn't be launching an attack
calls are already growing for millie to
be fired over these offenses and if true
he has a lot to answer for it in two
weeks when he testifies before congress
let's bring in former white house press
secretary and co-host of outnumber
kaylee mceninny
kaylee i definitely wanted you to be on
the program to answer to this because
you were in the administration did y'all
suspect this was going on
no i mean look it was eye-opening when
we walked to the church i was with
president trump st john's church we all
remember when it burned in that riot uh
i walked with general milley i walked
with president trump to that church
general milley was there he happily
obliged in that movement and then the
day after apologized and said that he
shouldn't have done it so certainly that
was eye-opening but lawrence you know i
got to say this my jaw dropped open
today when i saw this reporting i hope
it's not true and i say i hope it's not
true because i don't trust the reporting
of bob woodward unlike most journalists
liberal journalists who just buy it hook
line and sinker i don't i question it
but if this is true lawrence if this is
true that in the very oval office i was
sitting in that general milly was
talking to the commander-in-chief
president trump and outside of those
meetings was back channeling to china
saying i'll let you know if there's ever
an attack on you i'm paraphrasing there
if that was happening that is aiding and
abetting the enemy there's a word we
have for that i won't say because i
don't want to get there yet because i
don't trust the reporting of bob
woodward but that is simply stunning in
every sense of the word well kaylee we
know leaks were happening
and obama during his administration when
he had leaks he went after his leakers
we still don't know
who the leakers were actually we know
one of them vinman who has already said
and we got a tweet from him that that
millie needs to resign
yeah yeah exactly because civilians
control the military the civilian
commander-in-chief not the military
general who's not only back channeling
to china but also saying you know buck
the orders if there was an ever in order
on the nuclear front you know buck those
orders is essentially what he was saying
and lawrence i have to ask the guy who
says that he should have been leading
the way he's the right one on foreign
policy on national security well i do
have this reporting that i talked to a
very high level intelligence official
who told me this he said he sat in the
oval i was not in this meeting but he
was asked by president trump how long
would it take for afghanistan to fall if
there was not an interim government in
place a coalition government
that high-level intelligence official
said very quickly mr president to which
president trump responded it would fall
in two days he said this in front of
general milley who then went on to the
biden administration to orchestrate the
devastating fall of afghanistan where 13
service members died i trust the guy who
said afghanistan's going to fall in two
days not the guy who sat in the meeting
and failed to communicate that
information to the next
commander-in-chief who then oversaw the
fall of afghanistan and the devastating
images we all saw not just that kaylee
as you've noted before this the guy that
made the call just the other day well
they may have gotten the wrong guy and
they targeted civilians
this is the joint's chief god that is
all knowing
yeah it's the guy who called it a
righteous strike a righteous strike
which keep in mind president biden this
is his administration the righteous
strike that killed a humanitarian aid
worker if the new york times reporting
is true and seven children and the guy
was carrying water bottles but yet they
target him as if he's an isis k member
we've got more to the story to come out
we've got to make sure that new york
times reporting is true but you're
exactly right he green lighted the
righteous strike that ended in the death
of seven children you know kaylee i'm no
rocket scientist but i believe my eyes
all i can say is i notice a difference
from the millie and the trump
administration and then when they walked
over
um to the church to now it seems like
there's been a little flip-flopping
going on with millie am i missing
something
no it certainly does and lawrence i
learned this the hard way um you know we
hear about the deep state and you know
the folks over at liberal news network
say it doesn't exist it does exist
lawrence i communicated with the deep
state in the hallways and i can tell you
the people who are very nice to your
face the dr anthony falci's general
milly and then you find out in the
aftermath that they've totally flipped
the other way they've existed in
washington in the case of dr fauci for
decades making wrong decisions for the
american people you know on fauci's part
saying mass work they don't work you
know trying to save mass for our
healthcare workers but lying to the
american people they're nice to your
face they're part of the deep state but
they're undermining the
commander-in-chief along the way if it's
a republican commander-in-chief as they
did to president trump
undermining the president of the nice
united states to get the adults back in
the room that have completely messed
this entire situation up i guess
elections do have a consequence caitlyn
thanks so much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else